皆さん文教ビュー使ってましょういろんな文房具使ってると思い
見てもう住所とか誰が住んでる方がバレすぎて枝はじめの隣にペンで書くはじめした
とって書いてある
分かりやすくてありがとうもうそんな配達員とも仲良しな肇社長なんですけどもこれ
すごいんですよ
ペンってだいたい年がそんな高級なもんとかといっても値段があるといえば券取っても
あると思うんですよまん
鉛筆まで行ったら外れに高いと思うんですけども某イベントがたかが知れてると思うん
ですよね
そんな中今回準備したこちら段屋でしたっけ
でそんな高くなかったぁー
7,160円ですまあまあが待ってください待ってくださいこれ違うんですすごいです
これ中身タッキーノッペってるだけですけどいろんな機能がついてるってそれの多分最
高級レベルだと思うんですよさっそく開けていきましょう
[音楽]
を出てきましたもうこれがこれだこちらこちらおそらく史上最強の多機能ペンシー
クイーンま
レッズファンクションペン6つの軌道が入っている多機能ペンでございますさあ色が3
色展開されておりますちょっとどれが入ってるこれもわかりません私海外から取り入れ
ている商品なんで俺もなんか正直どんな機能がついてるのかよく分かってないんですよ
なぁで見てきたペンの中だとトップレベルでいろんな機能ついている印象があります
オープンのプライス
これかこちらですねうーんわー
めっちゃマルエー説明書からこれ
うわぁ
おいイングで種すべてが英語で記されていますまーすげーー
相手の usb ますツイてるってそもそも本当にペンラんかなこれ
あ一応か気はしますね駆け足ますけれどもなんかデザインが本当に不思議ですねから見
てどう見ても猫れた不携帯として使えるんですよ電話ですね顔とでるとこあるはは絶対
カメラでしょこれ
壱岐商ついてます
ボタンを押すところまずどういったこれ前につくかどうとしていたりしたのかは応募た
んでしょこれ直してについたりするかな
ん
10分
負担や e 5巻やんげなんだなぁ
ああ絶対ここで充電するなれば充電できそうな場所があるんです10年4月ます完全に
充填2型じゃないんですけどすごいすごいボールペンにこんな充電しますかんでるの
4位は大江だのヌンチャク暇になると思うんでさっき日本のペンの機能を紹介したいと
思いますその1
ライトがついてます
まぁ今の時代 iphone とかも光る子ですし
性も中でも点が光るお掃除役立つと思います続いてえっ
mp3 mp 4の再生ができまあこの小さい画面で動画とか音楽聴けるって事
でしょうか
その3写真撮れますはいて幅ほどカメラでしょうねうはにあたなんと盗撮に使うす
大丈夫これ
柄は使わないですよ使う使わない横してもう一つんけど
ロックオンできますまあいいですねペンで録音なんても悪い話でを録音するイメージ
しかないんですけどなぁ
そして毎月のハンドライティングどういう意味
お餅とが売ってるんですかねこれやばいくつのバルーン野郎がんばれ
タイピング30分くらいは女子中で行け言葉体と思うのでそうその点が着くと思います
復縁の望みてきましたもっちゃん
いきます
期待のでたまごっちみたい oooo 何が起きてるんだ
フェーズ1でまだまだ前
音が完全に携帯なんだはガラケーみたいなことをするこれ見えますでしょうか
目が普通にねガラケーの画面みたいなんですがこれえこれどういって音楽とかなん
だろう何とかす使いこなしですやはり simカードを言ってくださいって出てるけど
おけば嬉しい目感じれたらもうこれ多分形態になるならこれ着実に使える金もちょっと
いくって言っていっぱいっ
うん今日
やばいやばいき茶きたきたきた
見えますこれあれだが不細工じゃねぇこれは現在これで写真が撮れるわけですよ
すごい
a これじゃ版や普通にないんで盗賊に使えそうだなぁ2とこで使わせるほど気をつけ
てくださいね
by 4つなぎましたこれで音楽とが流せるということをやばいよそれボール年から曲
流れるのはすごいと思いません
えっっ
やばいやばいやばい
[音楽]
流れてないんですけどその方
5/ s 5
すごいわー
ただ使い道がわからないですね凄い凄い電話メールメッセージ
マルチメディア中多分動画とか見てるんでしょうねいろいろできるぽいねこれ
フォークルトア
を光ってのああ
光りましたこれでだったと知るカード出たらこんな感じだとまず電話で一つねこれ数で
押すもし入っていやすごいは多機能ペンでさあこれはちゃんのカメラもつきましたし
音楽も流せる
おっすげーラジオ70危険だ
本当にラジオ7日から10本やんでもちゃんの fm ラジオって書いてあるねこれ
ラジオ聴けてますねこれ
いやーこれ何柱を聞きでますよこれすごい安い乳母らしいですねほんとにいろんな機能
がありますこれはもういろんな文房具が出てますねこれも文具といいますかもう
デジタルツールですよ一つのいやすごいは本当にでも
税務スマホでできちゃう
あっはぁし